regardez ce que j'ai reçues la regarder
toute nouvelle smartwatch de mode vol
c'est la tique watch eux deux
[Musique]
molle je vous en ai déjà parlé et j'ai
le temps je vous ai présenté leurs
écouteurs intra auriculaires
il ya quelque temps encore avant je vous
avais présenté une de leurs smart watch
qui est la tique watch pro il ressortit
au cs 2019 la tique watch s2 et
l'attique watch eu 2 6 kw h eux deux que
j'ai employé ici est cool
franchement cool j'ai déjà bien aimé si
vous vous souvenez
si vous avez lu ma précédente vidéo sur
la tic aux pros sinon je vous invite à
l'est la visionner je continue à bien
aimer les produits de mode veille
ils ont des produits qui sont toujours
vachement bien positionnés à des tarifs
pas hyper cher il ya la qualité derrière
tout ça fonctionne sur where os de
google enfin je vous explique
je vais vous montrer tout ce qu'on peut
faire avec 7 e 2 vous allez faire plein
de choses je vais pouvoir aller nager
dans la piscine vous allez pouvoir aller
courir à l'extérieur
vous allez pouvoir vous remuez tous les
côtés parce que l'adn de base d'une
smart watch alors vous me direz c'est
donner l'heure oui mais c'est pas
réellement ça l'adn de base d'une smart
watts et une monde connecté pour les
gens qui font les activités physiques
ça peut être de la musculation s'appelle
de la natation ça peut être de la course
à pied ça pète de la marche rapide ça
peut être plein de choses mais c'est
avant tout la base parce que vous avez
un capteur de rythme cardiaque parce que
vous avez un accéléromètre ça permettra
pas mal de choses et en plus là dessus
vous avez un gps galileo enfin je vais
vous expliquer c'est assez intéressant
en faire un petit tour il va regarder
est ce que cette tique watch e2 pouvait
refaire voilà donc l'ati coach de alors
l'ati coach de l est plutôt cool vous
faire pas mal de choses avec j'ai déjà
vous montre un peu la navigation hop
vous partez sur le côté ça vous montre
votre nombre de pas vous voyez
aujourd'hui j'ai pas été hyper hyper
actif vous revenez en arrière de l'autre
côté en face ça vous dit quelle journée
quelle est la température quelle est la
météo s'il fait beau oui ou non vous
pouvez faire pas mal de choses avec les
minuteurs ça c'est google assistant donc
ça c'est toute la partie intelligence de
notre ami et google assistant on revient
sur le haut vous avez les réglages vous
avez quelques réglages intéressant sur
votre monde pour régler l'écran les
gestes la collectivité a failli à pas
mal de petites choses
bon ça c'est un grand standard mais
c'est franchement cool hop on revient en
arrière et sur le bas vous retrouvez
toutes vos notifications sur le plat
store sur la gestion de votre page sur
youtube le mot
lindy une compagnie enfin bref vous avez
un petit peu tous ici et ça c'est assez
intéressant
ensuite vous avez un bouton et un seul
bouton qui se situe sur la droite vous
appuyez dessus et vous avez accès à vos
applications vous avez tous dans sas et
les applications de base vous pouvez en
télécharger plein d'autres votre
planning vous avez tous vos gestion de
votre agenda vous synchronise avec votre
compte google vous avez votre place tort
ça c'est cool parce que vous avez plein
d'applications à venir télécharger pour
le sport pour le travail la productivité
vous avez des cadrans vous pouvez
également venir télécharger et des
choses qui sont recommandés pour vous en
voyez il ya là la boussole et pas mal de
petites choses enfin ça c'est coupe
l'accès au camp mais vraiment de
rajouter plein d'applications et plein
de fonctionnalités à votre montre donc
sa j'adore
bien évidemment alarme chronomètre
confidences étaient molles contact tous
vos contacts ça c'est aussi hyper cool
et puis vous arrivez sur les exercices
exercice fit fit fit respiration c'est
vraiment ça l'adn de ce produit qui est
destiné aux sportifs marche à pied
course à pied vélo musculation vous avez
vraiment de quoi vous aider à faire du
sport et pour moi c'est très clairement
l'adn de ce produit dont vous voyez j'ai
absolument pas été actif aujourd'hui
j'ai franchement fait ma besace la
partie respiration vous allez pouvoir
respirer pendant 1 minute 50 la sic
inspirez expirez l'idée c'est de
relâcher un petit peu c'est pas mal
lampe de poche météo minuteur bon ça je
vous le passez nager dans la piscine
vous avez donc votre application pour
nager dans la piscine alors vous allez
nager je suis pas un très très grand
nageur mois donc ne m'en voulez pas vous
réglez vos longueurs vous choisissez
vous avez pas mal de possibilités
ça c'est cool en étant moi même pas du
tout un grand sportif ni un champion de
natation j'ai pas trop vous aiguiller là
dedans en tout cas c'est vraiment tout
l'adn de ce produit et ça franchement si
hyper intéressant après vous à d'autres
fonctionnalités le planning les rappels
tic santé petit footing exercices ti
classement ça vous donne un classement
par rapport à d'autres tease à tort de
la montre pour site vous motiver
quelqu'un qui viendra à votre rythme
cardiaque tic santé que donnera pas mal
d'infos sur mode dépenses quotidiennes
voyez aujourd'hui j'ai vraiment été très
très très très mauvais de la traduction
trouve et iphone enfin voilà après et
pas mal de choses et justement pour la
natation ce qui est intéressant c'est
que c'est une bombe qui est complètement
étanche vous pouvez aller nager jusqu'à
5 atm
vous pouvez aller nager en pis et vous
pouvez les faire du surf avec ça c'est
vrai que c'est cool c'est monté très
complète qui est très complète pour
toutes les activités que vous fassiez du
running du
vélo de la musculation de la marche à
pied de la marche rapide de la natation
des sports aquatiques en règle générale
c'est un compagnon idéal qui vous
donnera à plein de résultat et ça c'est
franchement intéressant et yacht show
c'est super intéressante et qui vient
d'arriver ses tics motion à leurs tics
motion c'est de l'intelligence
artificielle pour votre activité en gros
il ya pas plus de capteurs sont toujours
les mêmes capteurs c'est du traitement
logiciel derrière qui est fait grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle je vais vous
prendre par exemple la natation lorsque
vous allez aller nager tic motion va
être en mesure de reconnaître le type de
nage le nombre longueur vous avez fait
est bien évidemment votre battement tout
au long de la session face à ça c'est
intéressant parce que ça va vraiment
devenir complètement optimisé et autre
chose qui est assez intéressant n'avait
pas forcément besoin de lancer votre
monde dans un vol spécial car je vais
courir tâche des marchés tient je me
repose tite motion sera exactement
l'activité vous faites à un instant t
si vous courez si vous vous reposez si
vous allez dormir si vous nagez et
pourra vous donner des stades qui sont
vraiment performante
j'imagine que c'est un croisement couplé
entre votre position gps entre fréquence
de rythme cardiaque entre
l'accéléromètre
j'imagine que ça prend en gros toutes
ces données et grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle ça permettra savoir
exactement ce que vous êtes en train de
faire et ça pour coup c'est assez
intéressant
après d'un point de vue purement
esthétique je trouve que mof veille a
vraiment fait un très très très joli
boulot là dessus sur ce modèle là sur
lie de l est disponible uniquement en
noir ce qu on pourrait regretter c'est
qu'effectivement elle est quand même
relativement épaisse après ça dépend des
poignets ça dépend des mains de chacun
si vous cherchez quelque chose de
vraiment très très faim c'est pas
forcément la montre qui va vous plaire
mais moi par exemple qui est un petit
poignée franchement ça ne choque
absolument pas elle s'attache
franchement y perd facilement elle
trouve très facilement sa place autour
de votre poignet voyez bon je trouve que
ça c'est franchement bien réussi point
de vue design je trouve assez calice et
du polycarbonate
le bracelet est en silicone il est
complètement interchangeables c'est du
22 mm
l'écran est diagonale de 1,39 pouces et
un écran amoled de 4 cents par 400
pixels
ouais franchement je la trouve très bien
très lumineuse très agréable elle
tournait qu'un qualcomm snapdragon ou
air 2100 c'est pas la toute dernière
génération des qualcomm snapdragon boere
néanmoins ça fonctionne pas mal du point
de vue autonomie
vous la gardez une journée et demi après
il faut la recharger vous avez une
batterie de 415 millions terreur c'est
vrai que simone veil avait intégré le
qualcomm snapdragon were la dernière
génération on aurait gagné en autonomie
ça aurait pu être intéressant néanmoins
comme ça c'est vrai que ça fait déjà
plutôt bien la faire alors après en
collectivité je vous le disais vous avez
du bluetooth 4.1
vous avez du gps glonass beidou galileo
bien évidemment un accéléromètre un
gyroscope le capteur de fréquence
cardiaque
il y a absolument pas de nfc à
l'intérieur donc aucune possibilité
d'avoir du paiement dématérialisé et
elle marche bien évidemment avec android
et ios
l'ati coach devient vraiment compléter
la gamme de mots boys
moi j'ai notamment testé la tique auch
pro je voulais dire que j'ai vraiment
adoré l'ati coach de l'attique watch s2
qui sera plus pour les sportifs
chevronnés sur la oude d'or pour moi la
fille coach de l est vraiment pour eux
je dirais de l'urbain casuals type alive
taille
en gros si vous avez une vie plutôt
citadine que vous faites du sport sur la
course à pied sur la salle de sport sur
la natation piscine
je pense que l'un d'eux est très bien si
vous êtes plus maintenant un baroudeur
vous allez plus en montagne que vous
avez plus dans des conditions un peu
plus extrêmes
la s2 sera mieux tout simplement parce
qu'elle une certification militaire et
qu'elle sera beaucoup plus robustes par
contre pour la vie de tous les jours la
l2 est franchement top c'est vrai
qu'elle a un look sport mais le fait que
vous puissiez changé notamment le
bracelet paraître un petit peu la
customiser et de la mettre plus
facilement votre double moi je la trouve
en tout cas très sympa j'aime vraiment
le fait que maud voight plus loin au
niveau de l'intelligence artificielle
pour ans les usages encore plus
pertinent beaucoup plus transparent et
sans s'embêter son sabre et mon couleurs
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que cette tique watch e2 pourrait
vous intéresser
est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté l
attique watch pro est ce que vous avez
une montre connecter ce que vous voyez
l'usagé en dehors du fait de donner
l'heure parce que vous pouvez faire
quelque chose avec
vous avez google assistant vous pouvez
passer des coups de fil avec vous pouvez
envoyer des messages pourraient faire
beaucoup de choses
envoyer des messages ça marche avec
google assistance est très simple la par
exemple offre je me mets sur le numéro
justin qui m'accompagne si vous ne le
savez pas coucou ma chérie j'espère que
tu vas dire coucou ma chérie j'espère
que tu vas bien envoyé annulé up
j'envoie sa part directement alors bien
évidemment il est relié à mon smartphone
parce qu'il fonctionne pas tout seul
vous pouvez passer des appels
téléphoniques directement avec votre
montre il ya pas mal de choses c'est ce
que ça vraiment très très intéressant
donc dites moi ce que vous en pensez et
en plus une goutte qui est pas hyper
cher elle coûte 159 euros 99
je trouve franchement très intéressante
vu le prix donc si elle vous botte vous
aimez bien évidemment un lien en bas
dans la description on va reparler le
deux mondes connectés parce que je suis
ça vraiment vraiment intéressant il ya
de belles avancées il ya de belles
innovations il ya nos produits et avec
l'intelligence artificielle on fait
toujours plus de choses donnent rendez
vous dès demain je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous ciao
[Musique]